so for Francis he has to to be able to
bank on yourself and walk away from that
type of money and that type of exposure
in the UFC there has to be some sort of
negotiating going on in the boxing world
that we don't know about that's the only
valid point I can think of why France
would turn down this insane deal to be
the highest paid uh UFC heavyweight of
all time and you know we're off from
Brock Lesnar money when I was 12 years
ago at least 10 years ago so it's like
okay you know it's like okay
um still
there has to be potential you know [__]
you money involved I assume that's
boxing so for Francis this is more than
just
makes martial arts and his legacy in the
UFC this there has to be some sort of
game to unboxing that's why I walked
away